foreign
doing something else
you've never seen my face before
I was on the train there was an
explosion
I couldn't remember anything exception
you were a spy like me if you touch me
I'm gonna scream catch
I thought you were gonna catch it you
better back up and then I was going to
be like Ben how come you can do that
right
[Music]
it was a myth who you were was Citadel a
spy agency loyal to no Nation
eight years ago they were double crossed
by one of our own
creating a new order
it's only a matter of time understood
and now I need your help what's going on
here it's the only way
never find out
[Music]
you need to remember the past
to save the future
[Music]
are you ready
so you left me a few new toys yes I
built them for my favorite spot oh he
hated them and I didn't want them to go
to waste